what do you know about education they'll
tell you it's about getting a job
becoming a well-educated member of
society lifting your family out of
poverty but you want to know what it's
really about what do you see a kid from
louisiana going to university i see a
hundred and four thousand dollars in
college tuition after scholarship aid
forty seven thousand dollars in
on-campus accommodations seven thousand
dollars and books textbooks and college
supplies i see a total of a hundred
fifty nine thousand three hundred forty
dollars in revenue over the next four
years of this poor suckers life that is
what it costs for one american to get
through a respectable college but that's
not all see this kid's parents can't
afford 160 000
so they're gonna take out a student loan
and before coven that student loan will
return five percent every year over 10
years which comes up to an additional 43
000 and pure interest from just one
customer
that means the lifetime value of a
student can be as high as 200 000 or
more
over 44 million americans are 1.6
trillion dollars in student debts you
heard me right 1.6 trillion that is the
size of canada's entire economy and that
is what higher education is really about
education isn't about getting you ready
for life it's about money you smell them
opportunity
no money
i smell money anyone who disagrees with
it is either in it or stupid but it
wasn't always this way see before
student loans universities used to be
somewhat affordable and reasonable
but today it's brought into a very
profitable industry for those at the top
where naive kids are shoved in and out
comes obedient death slaves this is the
education industrial complex
[Music]
thankfully college isn't the only way to
make money anymore more and more people
are realizing that the only thing you
need to make money is an internet
connection and a desire to learn new
skills that is where brilliant comes in
brilliant is a website and app that
provides you with fun interactive
courses in science technology and math
computer science the average computer
scientist makes 106 000 a year and
brilliant has a learning path that gives
you a solid foundation in the subjects
quantum computing engineers they make
135 000 a year on average brilliant has
an exciting course for that too there's
one on data science another one of
probability statistics and finance and
much more and what makes brilliant
different from everything else is that
it focuses on learning by doing instead
of hours of boring lectures or textbook
exercises with really you get to jump
right into solving problems and
exercising your knowledge while being
coached little by little until you find
that you've learned a fundamental
concept in stem plus you get instant
feedback along the way so you can
improve as fast as possible there are no
tests or exams just choose what you're
into and get started and to get you
started brilliant is giving you 20 off
when you go to brilliant.org jake tran
with the link below that's brilliant.org
trying to sign up for free and get 20
off thanks to brilliant for sponsoring
this video
[Music]
october 4th 1957 the day russia reviewed
it had built a rocket so powerful that
launched the first man-made satellite
into space sputnik 1. if the soviets
could send a satellite into space there
was little doubt they could send a
nuclear bomb to the us so the race was
on
now here is a photograph released by the
soviets of the satellite and this is the
track of what you will see in the lower
half of your television screen so be
sure that you watch very very
carefully and at the helm of this
competition to outsmart and outperform
the soviets was senate majority leader
lyndon b johnson according to johnson
the soviets had won this battle due to
higher education if america was planning
on winning the war it would need a lot
more college grads the problem was even
though tuition back then was pennies on
the dollar compared to today it still
wasn't cheap per se and student loan
programs were extremely selective
johnston wanted to change that so he
went to congress he explained how
college grads earn an average of a
hundred thousand dollars more over 30
years compared to non-grads therefore
they could easily pay back a student
loan if we gave one to them and this was
in the name of defeating the evil
soviets how could you not support
something like this
the government liked what he was selling
so in september 1957 president
eisenhower signed the cleverly named
national defense education act which
created the national defense student
loan program this basically combined two
of america's favorite buzzwords national
security and education national security
education national security education
national security education there was no
way this was not going to pass so just
11 months after spudnex launch the us
government entered the student loan
business the national defense student
loan program started by offering schools
money to give eligible students a loan
up to a thousand dollars a year enough
to cover tuition to give you some
perspective the average income back then
was around five thousand dollars a
family congress had only approved a
specific amount of these loans and
pretty soon the money ran out but by
then thousands of students had gone to
colleges thanks to these loans so the
higher ups of higher education had
gotten a whiff of what was possible if
they played their cards right the us
government could bankroll their entire
business so they pushed for the program
to expand and it did over and over the
loan program ran out of money and over
and over again congress would vote to
give it more money people were paying
off their loans they were becoming more
educated and the us was on track to
leave the soviets in the dust it was
working then lyndon b johnson became
president and life got even better he
was a true believer in the american
dream and he wanted everyone to have a
shot at achieving it by the mid-1960s
the government was paying out so much
money to fund student loans the federal
spending limit topped 100 billion
dollars for the first time ever
president johnson wanted to keep
expanding the student loan program even
more but suddenly congress got nervous
all of this money was flowing out but it
took at least four years to see any sort
of repayments and when the repayment
started it was an increment spread out
over many years so he found an
alternative he turned to the banks for
help and by doing that he created one of
the worst debt traps the world has ever
seen the modern student loan system
[Music]
in 1965 congress passed a higher
education act it was the basis for the
system we have today where poorer
students are offered scholarships or
grants and middle class students get
guaranteed loans to do this they created
a guarantee agency that would make sure
the banks kept giving out loans as usual
banks and lenders would give out student
loans then the government would give the
guarantee agency 80 of the money the
student borrowed that way if the student
defaulted the guarantee agency would
fully reimburse the bank for the money
they lost plus the interest they would
have made
the standard rate to repay a student
loan was set at 6
so while the students were studying and
not making money the government would
pay the rate to the banks nine months
after graduation that responsibility
would fall onto the students
in johnson's eyes it was the perfect
system college grads would get great
degrees land high paying jobs and repay
that debt easily allowing even more
students to take out loans at least that
was the plan see this created a very
lucrative feedback loop for schools
suddenly thousands of people who would
have never been able to study suddenly
wanted to go to college in other words
demand skyrocketed while supply remained
the same to address this extra demand
colleges simply raised their tuition
rates you see colleges had the leverage
now the government had overplayed his
hand it has shown how badly it wanted
america to be the most educated nation
on earth so colleges knew no matter how
high they wanted to raise their prices
the government would always be there to
subsidize the money the government
didn't care how much it cost because it
wasn't their money students and parents
didn't care because they were getting a
loan anyways and that's exactly what
colleges started to do in the 60s
colleges raised tuition 30 above
inflation and this negative feedback
loop only got worse colleges expanded
they grew into massive institutions with
multiple campuses and hundreds of
well-paid professors all thanks to the
freedom to charge as much tuition as
they liked
[Music]
sally mae was created to serve an urgent
need banks didn't have any more money to
offer students and the government didn't
want to lose its education momentum it
needed a new way to fund loans so in
1972 sallie mae was pitched as the
solution banks would loan to students
and then sally mae would buy those loans
from the banks allowing them to continue
lending sally mae would then make back
all the money the students repaid plus a
neat little profit off the top in 1969
tuition at a private college was around
fifteen hundred dollars a year ten years
later it had more than doubled by 1975
so many people had gone to college and
were competing for the same jobs that
thousands of students defaulted on their
loans they couldn't find jobs that paid
enough to repay their loans to make
matters worse the clinton administration
offered student loans directly from the
federal government they were cheaper
than anything banks could offer and for
a while it looked like the end of sallie
mae but in 1994 republicans took power
and moved to privatize sallie mae i.e
they turned sally made into a private
company now sally may didn't have to
rely on the government approval for
anything instead they could borrow from
investors and offer much larger student
loans at much higher interest rates
creating an incredibly profitable
business all this convoluted stuff meant
that for colleges the mix of private and
government student loans meant that the
sky was the limit they could raise their
prices as much as they wanted
universities had stumbled upon a
universal truth if you want to charge
more money either create a monopoly or
get the government to subsidize it the
student loan trap as we know it has
merged into its final form
[Music]
on making sure the public schools all
across america fulfill the promise make
sure every child is educated and not one
single child
gets left behind in america by the 2000s
a year's tuition was sending around 20
000
a 13 x increase and the competition
between sallie mae and federal student
loans was tougher than ever sallie mae
would pay college loan officers to
recommend sallie mae as the best loan
provider they would place sallie mae
employees at college call centers
tricking students into thinking that
they were talking to a student counselor
and that sally may was really the best
option for them they sponsored cruises
and luxury trips for college financial
advisors and the federal government just
couldn't keep up and when george bush
took office in 2001 he made sallie mae's
life even easier by cutting back
government student loans even more i
graduated with degrees in aerospace
engineering
in
1999.
i borrowed about 45 000 for school since
that time
my
student loan debt has exploded
to where currently i owe about a hundred
and three thousand dollars by 2007 the
federal loan program had lost 40 of a
share of the student loan markets when
no one standing in its way sally may
call on every lobbyist propagandist and
political influence it could find to
sell the american dream to sell the idea
that success starts with a college
degree and sally may found an unlikely
ally barack obama
[Music]
and a four-year degree earns you a
million dollars more than if you just
had a high school degree think about
that
i mean a million dollars that's that's
real money when obama became president
in 2009 his solution to the financial
crisis was in part to make america's
workforce the most educated in the world
playing directly into the hands of
companies like sally may he asked every
american to attend college even for just
a year and a year was all sally mae
would need to enslave his students what
obama had helped would alleviate the us
economy actually tightened the grip
around people's throats sure he tried
making life easier with things like
capping student loan payments at 15 of
the borrower's income but that just made
it an even easier sale for students to
get in debts and for colleges to raise
prices the longer it took for students
to pay off their loans the more money
sally made made in interest obama played
right into the hands of the lenders by
2012 student debt hit one trillion
dollars
[Music]
for universities it was no longer a game
of who can provide the best education it
was now a game of who can offer the most
education air quotes who has the biggest
campus who has the most useless degrees
to choose from who has the best sports
teams who has the best extracurricular
activities who has the best amenities
many compete by advertising luxury they
promote things like lobster dinners
students will come to us and say
this is what sealed the deal used to be
reading writing and arithmetic well
we're now the fourth r recreation this
is a public school taxpayers fund that
spring break we also fund years of study
and subjects unlikely to help students
get jobs like social justice gender
studies multicultural studies what's
powerful is that for most sketchy
businesses it's pretty well known that
sketchy think nestle monsanto wall
street but higher education they have
the entire american culture cheering
them on they even have your own parents
cheering them on what started out as a
campaign to make higher education more
accessible has led to a psychotic 3 000
increase in costs and a generation of
debt slaves this is the education
industrial complex where the ones that
benefit the most are the universities
politicians and bankers almost half the
students who get loans don't graduate in
six years many won't ever pay off their
loans today american students carry
about one and a half trillion dollars in
federal student loan debt so taxpayers
lose students lose i owe 108 137
the winners are rich colleges
[Music]
huh
[Music]
[Music]